what is going on everybody welcome to
the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and black panther to
wakanda forever is the next upcoming
marvel studios movie and of course fans
want to know when exactly are we getting
our first trailer for the movie because
of course there are a lot of unanswered
questions that we all have right now for
what exactly is going to be happening in
wakanda forever with the sad and tragic
passing of chadwick boseman everybody
was wondering what marvel studios was
going to do with their next black
panther film and then marvel studios
came out and said that they are not
going to recast t'challa however they
did not say that there would not be a
new black panther only that there
wouldn't be a new t'challa basically
stating that the character t'challa is
going to be put to rest with chadwick
boseman but needless to say that opened
up a ton of questions about what the
next film is going to be about so fans
are patiently and impatiently awaiting
that trailer which we should be getting
very very soon when exactly we're going
to get that i'll talk about that in just
a bit but the big question is what
exactly is marvel studios going to show
us in the black panther wakanda forever
trailer now keep in mind the first
trailer that we are going to be seeing
is indeed a teaser trailer and marvel
studios typically has their format of
how they release teaser trailers and
what they show in it and i believe we
have a good idea of what they're gonna
show in this trailer they really do love
to tease you but with this specific
movie since there are so many questions
revolving around what exactly is marvel
studios and the mcu going to do without
its black panther now i'm guessing that
this question and the death of chadwick
boseman and t'challa in the mcu is what
the trailer is actually going to focus
on plus of course some big teasers which
i'll talk about in just a bit now
typically marvel studios likes to give
us teaser trailers that are around a
minute and a half to two minutes long
give or take some seconds but what
marvel is kind of infamous for is
actually giving us a teaser that doesn't
truly represent what the movie is
actually going to be about they try to
give us some misdirection so we truly
don't guess the actual plot of the film
for example the thor love and thunder
teaser trailer didn't even show us gore
not a single time in fact they teased
omnipotent city and zeus in the trailer
but did not tease gore they did show us
a fallen god but didn't talk about it at
all the teaser was really about who thor
exactly is after avengers in-game and
him trying to find himself another
example is doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness the teaser and the
actual main trailer really made it seem
like doctor strange massively screwed up
with what he did in avengers infinity
war and end game and what he did in
spider-man no way home when in fact
these really didn't have anything to do
with the plot of multiverse of madness
the plot revolved around america chavez
and the scarlet witch but they made it
seem like doctor strange was the actual
villain and some of his variants as well
when indeed it was the scarlet witch
this is kind of a template that marvel
studios follows with their teasers
however i do not believe that they can
actually follow that template with
wakanda forever if the trailer is a
minute and a half to two minutes long
the first 30 seconds to a minute have to
focus on the death of t'challa perhaps
even opening with a funeral scene which
is going to be a very very different
feel than the first trailer that we got
for the first black panther film in fact
i wouldn't actually be surprised if this
entire teaser trailer was simply a
dedication and tribute to not only
t'challa but to chadwick himself so we
could be getting a little bit of info on
how t'challa dies in the mcu now i would
not expect any type of a flashback of
him in battle dying in battle i just
don't think that marvel studios is going
to do that since chadwick passed away in
real life i doubt they would show him
dying on the battlefield in the movie
even if it is just cgi of the black
panther suit what i'm expecting to most
likely see is shuri his mother queen
raimonda okoye the dora milaje nakia and
i'm sure mbaku is going to show up as
well and really anybody else that wants
to come and pay their respects we could
even get some cameos but i'm assuming
it's going to be very touching very
heartfelt and i'm sure we'll get some
flashbacks from the first wakanda film
captain america civil war and of course
avengers infinity war and avengers in
game now like i said that will probably
take up maybe the first 30 seconds to a
minute maybe even half of the trailer
the next part they're going to focus on
the plot and the teas it's a teaser
trailer of course they have to tease
something but of course they also have
to give us a little bit of what the plot
should be the first black panther
trailer was one minute and 52 seconds
and they spent about the first minute
with ulysses claw and agent ross sort of
explaining what wakanda actually was
talking about how most of the world
views it as a third world country but
really it's kind of like eldorado it's
an extremely rich country that is hidden
from the world and people who typically
find it and go in don't come out now
that was the explanation of what wakanda
was we don't need that anymore we need
the explanation of what happened with
t'challa and in answering this i
actually think we're going to be getting
a couple of different teases here and
one of the teases is who is going to be
the new black panther right now there
are several people kind of up for that
title we have shuri we have a koi we
have embaku heck there's rumors that
even killmonger could possibly come back
somehow but i don't believe that's going
to happen or we could even get multiple
black panthers this is going to take up
a decent amount of the actual plot and
is something that should be at least a
little bit teased in the trailer however
that is only one part of the actual plot
the other one is the big tease the
villain and the conflict between the
villain and the heroes now at this point
in time most people know that the
villain of the movie is going to be
namor and this is very exciting on a
bunch of different levels one namor is
just a really cool character two he's a
mutant in the comics and as i think most
people know by now marvel studios just
confirmed mutants in the mcu kamala khan
is our very first mutant not inhuman but
mutant so before we were kind of
thinking and kind of bummed out about
the fact that they were probably going
to make it to where neymar wasn't
actually a mutant but was maybe given
some powers by a certain artifact or
something along those lines but now that
marvel studios has introduced mutants in
the mcu there's a good chance that they
could stick true to namor being a mutant
which is super exciting but what is the
conflict between namor and wakanda this
is something that's going to probably
not be revealed too much this will
probably be the final tease of the
actual teaser trailer so the first part
will most likely talk about the passing
of t'challa paying their respects to
their king and of course chadwick in
real life then we should dive into the
question of who is going to be the next
black panther that should be combined
with some fight scenes fight scenes that
will kind of be unclear with who wakanda
is fighting but should lead up to the
big tease of namor being the main
villain of wakanda forever unfortunately
since it's a teaser trailer i don't
think we're going to find out much about
why namor is actually going to go at war
with wakanda i have plenty theories on
this which of course i'll go over in
another video but i would love to hear
your best theories on why you think
namor is going to be attacking wakanda
now as far as when to expect the actual
teaser trailer to release all eyes are
looking towards this weekend at san
diego comic con hall h where marvel
studios typically reveals anything major
that is up and coming and of course not
to mention we are less than four months
away from wakanda forever hitting
theaters that's about the time frame
where marvel studios typically likes to
release teaser trailers and of course
wakanda forever is the next
up-and-coming movie from marvel studios
so if there is any type of trailer
that's going to be released it should be
for wakanda forever some people are
thinking we could get footage but
typically marvel and disney would show
the trailer first before we got any type
of footage at least that is released
publicly that's what they did for star
wars celebration with the andor trailer
they showed it but they also released it
online and most of us are assuming that
this is pretty much what's going to
happen at sdcc and if it doesn't happen
sdcc d23 is right around the corner as
well either way it should be very very
soon so let me know your best
predictions for the trailer in the
comments down below don't forget to give
the video a like and subscribe so you
can stay up to date on all things marvel
and mcu for live updates you can follow
me on twitter and instagram and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof